c'est un déménagement par étape logique
puisque nous sommes en diffusion
permanente
la radio a pris possession de ses locaux
cette nuit et le week-end aussi a
démarré depuis très tôt ce matin
c'est une immense fierté pour moi en
tout cas d'avoir assisté à ce
déménagement très et mouvements pour les
poules les équipes lourd aussi à
supporters parce qu'il s'agit aussi de
s'adapter à de nouveaux locaux à de
nouveaux usages
tout se passe correctement et j'espère
que ce sera également le cas en tout cas
en fit ou pro pour la télévision qui va
qui va déménager très bientôt
c'est une réalité et cela faisait des
années que la station que les personnels
attendent et ce déménagement le public
aussi nous avons eu beaucoup beaucoup
plus adapté à nos objectifs à nos
projets beaucoup plus moderne au coeur
de la de fort de france dans la ville
capitale
c'est extrêmement important nous avons
une série de projets à développer à
partir de 2019 que nous proposons à
toutes et à tous nous avons les
associations autour où nous avons les
institutions nous avons la population
foyalaise et au delà de fort de france
c'est un signal fort pour nous nous
sommes dans mon point de vue beaucoup
plus près de la population aujourd'hui